boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are on site at Co fest 2019 the Congress
on the future of engineering software
for our second annual partnership with
them we are very very excited we are now
sitting down with the Microsoft industry
experiences team in cloud and AI
engineering we have Paul we have air
jank and we have Diego thank you for
joining us on the show you three it's
very nice to have you I'm very excited
to talk to you guys about what you're
working on I would love to know about
your team you have a crazy amount of
experience together somewhere around
like 45 years or more of experience in
this industry which is nuts
so teach us about your team why you're
here at Coe Fez thank you you make me
feel old with it with our 10 years so
yeah as you mentioned so I lead the the
industry experiences team at Microsoft
we sit within engineering and really
sort of our goal as we work across
industries specifically in my team we
look at of course manufacturing which is
why we're here at Co fest today but
scientist services insurance retail in
the healthcare also we cover the sort of
a broad gamut um in my team and our goal
is really very simple I mean number one
we want understand what we're seeing in
terms of trends in industry and
opportunity around digital
transformation and movement to the cloud
and then the team charter is really
focusing on are Mikes of partners and
helping them with their move to the
cloud so our end goal is if we think
about customer problems and their
opportunity and their journey around
transformation and disruption is to make
sure we have a thriving partner
ecosystem effectively solving those
problems at a point of mind and
obviously in our case we're very much
focused around the Microsoft cloud also
known as your of course I'm helping make
sure we onboard those partners in a good
way to our platform or cloud platform
and making sure that they're really
delivering value and efficiencies on our
cloud to the end customers and you know
specifically today and this week at Co
Fez were super excited we are platinum
sponsors so it's great to be here a few
snippets from the keynote as we kicked
off yesterday it's really nice to hear
some of the analyst feedback around to
have Microsoft on our journey and being
sort of much more it really elevated in
terms of our maturity around
factoring so it was great feedback to
hear about you know kind of the respect
that we're gaining in terms of all
momentum around really be focused on
around the industry verticals and in the
case of kotha is around manufacturing
yeah so excited to be a sponsor excited
to be in I you know it's a part of the
cohort of the the non-conference if you
will which is all about the
conversations and that's certainly one
of the goals of my team being here this
week is how do we immerse ourselves in
industry how do we immerse ourselves
with thought leaders in manufacturing
how do we land and how do we take those
learnings back to so we can help in
terms of our decision-making evolving
our cloud platform and fundamentally you
know our goal is to really build
connections and be connected to
community one one of the these crazy
keys that you said in there was that
there's so many different industries
that you are onboarding to the Microsoft
cloud to Azure and so I'm excited to
have you teach us about that a little
bit more later
Diego you had a keynote yesterday you
were speaking about the future of
manufacturing from the Microsoft view so
go ahead and teach us about that okay
yeah so so as a preface what we do is
under poll we have sub teams that
focusing on specific industries and the
idea is that is that we want to go out
and interact with with the industry to
make sure that we have all the partners
not just established ones but the
up-and-coming and the promising one on
our platform so that requires a
significant amount of knowledge and an
interaction with the industry world not
just cloud vendors we also understand
the industry and and in our case here in
these couches manufacturing so yesterday
I was talking about the the trends in
manufacturing and also the our areas of
focus so we we articulate our point of
view on the on the industry as a
basically for transformation pillars
that are enabled by by the cloud and and
our platform so the first one is all
about empowering the workforce and
it's more about about delivering the
right information to the workers in the
factory floor deliveries for example
work instructions using using mixed
reality and augmented reality to help
them execute a work instructions or
quality control the second pillar is
about delivering new services since now
products are connected to the Internet
of Things and to the cloud and ingesting
data that is an opportunity for for
manufacturers to deliver attached
services like predictive maintenance or
optimization that were not possible
before
so the third the third pillar is all
about optimizing manufacturing
operations so now that you have all
these machines and and all this
equipment connected to the Internet of
Things it's not only about ingesting all
this data but is analyzing it and
providing insight to the people so in
the factory floor so they can make
decisions on time as opposed to to
guessing or waiting for a decision and
the fourth and final pillar is all about
our imagining manufacturing so that that
speaks more about the the the virtually
infinite compute power that you have in
the cloud are the kind of things that
you can do now with simulation and
generative design that you just weren't
practical before so so we we establish
with the fine those four pillars and
some scenarios under the pillars and we
tell partners build solutions that align
to them and because we are not a
manufacturing software company we're a
platform company granted there are many
of our services in the platform that are
particularly interesting to
manufacturing like IOT machine learning
cognitive services etc but at the end of
the day we deliver the vision of
manufacturing through partners to
software vendors what else was just so
interesting when you're describing these
four main pillars is that you have on on
of
on a very on a very like futuristic
level you have a mixed reality that is
happening inside of the workforce and
this is a very major key to hopefully
what we see in the education system
where we are learning in spatial
intelligence in a way that it's just
helping us retain information and have
our awareness expanded to new ways of
thinking just much more quickly and so
that's a huge part of this as well as
predictive maintenance is very
interesting all the sensors that are
happening inside on all of the machines
and being able to it's kind of like
similar to our biometrics like we want
to be able to predict pathology before
it starts developing and we get sick so
same thing with the machines inside of
factories and then all of the data and
then reimagining I reimagining is such a
crucial part of both children and adults
lives and we can reimagine a better
world we can take these incremental
steps to figure out how to how to better
get to that to that goal now all right
with air jank so working with partners
technology trends in general solving
solutions to problems moving to the
cloud teach us about all of that I think
that's the most exciting player of of my
daily life for me it what matters is
always building something new and
working on the cloud especially on
Microsoft's cloud and looking at the
real problems people are talking about
here in a conference like Co Fez is very
crucial so I can go back and work on the
interesting solutions that you can put
together on the cloud given the fact
that there are many different services
that are available on Microsoft cloud
what I'm doing in my daily life is that
we're working really closely with Diego
here my daily life is all about working
with the partners that we have or
up-and-coming partners and looking
they're looking at their solutions and
how we can put it on the Microsoft cloud
at the most effective way I think the
key word here is the most effective
because people can argue that at the end
of the day this is a solution moving
parts moving technologies but we were
really talked
but a huge variety of different like
services choosing the right service and
I'm putting it in the right
configuration for soloing that problem
is usually the key so that's that's what
I focus on that's where I have the most
fun
so examples like when you look at the
typical situations or typical scenarios
in manufacturing and as Diego mentioned
looking from the business point of view
they all point to certain higher level
technology problems things like we're
talking about analyzing IOT data for
instance that actually translates into
at the highest level the first things
that you will think how am I going to
store the data how am I going to process
the data but that as you double-click
there's going to be more so more
questions like how am I going to secure
the data what are the things to make it
secure so that only the people who are
actually entitled to see the details and
the results can actually see it how am I
going to make it more performant how am
I going to make it high available so
that whenever I need to access the data
I want to make sure that they are there
so all of those problems are very
interesting and fun problems to solve as
you teach us about data it also reminds
me about all of the the conversations
that we've had with you know these
security leaders at IBM and these other
companies where they're explaining to us
this you know these Co centric circles
of security that they put up to to make
sure the data secure but then also like
you said how do you store it how do you
query it how do you analyze it how do
you make it most most relatable to what
you're actually working on that is a
very very important process this is it
is it okay to potentially say that part
of what you do when you work with the
partners is you identify what they what
they what they need and then you pair
them together with your cloud solutions
you know way you can you can say it that
way the code because if you look at the
platform where it says Diego national
before
we're a platform company we provide sub
services that can solve our building
blocks that control problems and when
you look at the building blocks you can
see it both at the variety and also
variety in terms of the capabilities but
also variety in terms of the abstraction
level let's let's pick up this example
of the abstraction level case for
instance very typical IOT problem and
you look at IOD situation on the cloud
is data ingestion data ng excuse me data
ingestion means that there needs to be
an endpoint that your dayt devices are
sending the data to and you need to
capture it in a way that you don't lose
the messages but also put them in order
etc and make sure that that that's
performant at the very level low level
what you can do is that you can choose
to have set of virtual machines with
services that are public or that are
open source lot like Kafka or like flink
and now you can install them there or
you can choose to have a higher level
abstraction service that's provided by
Microsoft cloud which is IOT hub so my
daily work made a life again is going
and looking at the partner have the
discussion to make sure that visa
because our trade is all about
trade-offs right so you may choose to
have you may choose to use this service
versus that service but there's also
tons of other things that you should
think about and at the end of the your
trade-off should be at a point that it's
optimum and it's the customized thing
for that team so just technology by
itself really doesn't mean a lot it
should also go for to the team and I
guess that's where we bring the
experience at the table together with
Diego and rest of the team so that we
can help the partner in the best way
when you speak about the variability in
both the capabilities and the
abstraction level that it really does
explain the complexity of what you're
dealing with and how to properly get
people the solutions they need also you
spoke about data ingestion and and
this this this term is very interesting
because you think about all of the data
that's coming from the IOT world and
then how to actually be able to you know
make sense of that data and make the
actions that you need to in order to
save the organization money and all
these types of of very important things
now Paul we have a lot of things
happening at Microsoft this is one of
the teams that you're working with now
does your team now what else is
happening at Microsoft at the high level
so it's a pretty broad question so I
mean of course at the core of kind of
you know Microsoft and all
transformation is cloud so you know
cloud is at the central of our future
so I'll kind of talk to within my
purview my remit sort of what what's
happening so in number one I think one
of the interesting things is you know if
you go back a few years we were
forward-thinking in terms of disrupting
as Microsoft ourselves and and so you
know obviously over it's historically
we've been known as a company around
things like Windows and Office and so on
so forth and then forward-looking
obviously we've transformed to moving
ourselves thinking about business models
and transformation to the cloud so
that's really super interesting is is
taking those learnings that we've had to
really sort of internally disrupt and so
when were having conversations with
customers and partners about that
conversation around transformation and
disruption we can be sort of genuine in
that dialogue and we can share aligning
so it's the more I spend a lot of time
doing that number two of course the big
thing that I would say in our
transformation beyond obviously building
our cloud platform Microsoft Azure is
really thinking about pivoting to
industry so again as we think about that
that transformation is a company before
you know we talk about ourselves as the
the you know the technology platform
company but of course we've had to
immerse ourselves and build much moral
knowledge around the industry themselves
so you know we've we've always had sort
of externally focused rolls around
industry and but even then Townley you
know as the name implies with my team
industry experiences and we sit within
engineering within cloud engineering we
even have built that radicalization
there so that is helping us really build
have much more of a meaningful
conversation with industry because we
have four leaders and people who have
come from industry so it helps us not
only in sort of external facing
activities around of go to market and
sales which we've historically done but
also internally as we're building out
our cloud platform having that
understanding of what industry needs and
being able to prioritize capabilities as
we build out the cloud platform has been
a very pivotal change for us so that's
kind of a second thing and third I think
with as we kind of look ahead just
across the company you know and carrying
on this theme of digital transformation
I think having real experiences now so
around the you know our cloud platform
has matured so I actually started out in
cloud in 2005 talking to analysts about
this thing called the cloud trying to
convince them that was the future fast
forward to my day job now is talking to
a lot of the universe thing called the
digital transformation officer saying
you know hey if you don't have a
transformation strategy you know you
better think about it pretty quickly and
so you know that that whole being able
to really be forward-looking and having
dialogues with customers now and
partners around that move to the cloud
having the maturity of our cloud
platform but also having some really
really significant wins in the
marketplace now that we can reference so
my point is cloud is not necessarily new
anymore it's now that we need people to
kind of play catch-up and we need to
engage with these digital transformation
officers and we need to get out which is
a big part of my role get out into
industry and share our learnings
share knowledge about the platform and
how cloud and cloud technologies can
help in that transformation so I'd
encourage people to think very very
carefully about understanding that you
know it's important to think about
transformation it's important to think
about cloud but also take the learnings
from others because there is lots lots
of great across industries lots of great
landings so I talk a lot about people
who it could be they're looking to
transform that business to building our
engineering organizations to building on
the cloud fundamentally take advice
bringing the experience leaders that can
help in that you know and that might be
people a lot of full-time on staff it
might be taking external consults and of
course closing the loop and looking back
at Microsoft we are a partnering
organization so you know those
organizations like myself I mean have
many many organizations that across
segmentations of customers and partners
and and kind of roles and
responsibilities where our goal is to
really build that connection I mean
historically we we are the cloud
platform company but we are a partner
and company and so for us to be
successful our goal if we think about
digital transformation and cloud is how
do we kind of really raise the watermark
so how do we make it much easier and
simple to take away the complexities of
building on cloud security compliance
regulations and so on that's all hard
stuff that we've built over time today
we have you know 54 regions on as we
think about cloud we have 70 plus
compliance certifications these these
are all built over time across industry
so the point I'm making is we're trying
to abstract away some of the the hard
things so that then our customers and
partners can really focus on high-value
IP focus on their competency get off in
building on the cloud super quick
leverage the capabilities that we're
providing on the cloud so I think that's
as I think about sort of pulling all
together you know myself and many of us
at Microsoft are all about how do we how
to engage in the industry how do we help
our customers and partners how do we
continue to take console to make sure
we're delivering value in our cloud
platform there is is really sort of on
point and needed and how do we share our
learnings and also I'd say the takeaway
is this Winkle cloud isn't necessarily
new now so there are lots of great
experiences so go take console go take
lanning's to set your future projects up
for success if I may add another answer
to your question and what is exciting
that's happening on the mic sort of
Microsoft world and put a spin on the
manufacturing industry so as Paul
mentioned it's all about increasing the
level of abstraction when you're
providing services and one example and
also the partnerships so one example of
Microsoft's partnership in the
manufacturing world is the partnership
with OPC foundation Microsoft OPC
foundation that's yes
so OPC has been around for quite some
time it's key for a lot of manufacturing
organizations it's all about connecting
the devices and machines in a secure way
a performant way etc and
over the years it morphed into or the
architecture moved into the new version
called OPC way and one key example here
is that Microsoft is the let me let me
try to put it English is still my second
language I'm still working on it
so let me put it in a way so Microsoft
is the organization single organization
that has got the largest or biggest
number of lions contributions in open
source on github with their reference
implementation showing how you can
implement OPC UA services so if you go
to OPC UA repo on github what you're
going to see is that contributions by
Microsoft on example so I can put
together an OPC service different a
different or P different component OPC
UA and one of the recent announcements
we had during the Hannover Messe
international as last week was that two
additional OPC UA services that are that
there are that can be used in connected
factory IOT solution one is OPC UA twin
service and the other is or PC wait Walt
service so and again if if you just go
back to the main themes here increasing
the level of abstraction so the services
can be used with less effort so which
basically democracy dev democratize is
the whole access to technology piece and
also the second part is partnership the
strong partnership between OPC
foundation and Microsoft also entailed
other partnerships like open
manufacturing platform which was also
announced last week between BMW group
and Microsoft the words that you're
using are interesting so you increase
the level of abstraction and then that
does that does that kind of make the
technology a little bit more of of a
black box at times though when when
people are trying to or potentially use
it but then that's potentially your role
as partners to make it less of a black
box for people to understand
I love that you actually catch caught on
that because that was that's that's very
typical way of you know like thinking
but if you just look at the
whole computing industry or what we've
been doing in the past when I just like
I need to admit I've been around for 25
plus years in computers in my my first
program was on the punch cards and I did
assignment level programming I did
programming on the C using C language on
the UNIX kernel etc but the those don't
go away the whole point here is that by
just providing higher level abstractions
you're letting more people to access
technology and do cool stuff but at the
same time if you want to double click
and getting get into the details it is
still available
right so so hence it was like the
discussion about IOT hub versus
installing Kafka on VMs you still have
the capability for putting together your
own service that runs on a different
deployment surface on the cloud which
accepts HTTP connections and now you can
still deal with all of the nitty-gritty
details it's still available however if
your staff is not really capable of
doing that or they don't have the they
are they might be capable but they may
not have the time then your choice is
going to go for a higher level service
take advantage of that so that you don't
have to think about the plumbing and
then build new capabilities on top so
you can always double click in to look
at the plumbing this is this is a good
way of explaining it ok so I like this a
lot
ok and then now um I want you guys to
walk us through what it's what it's like
for industry to use the Microsoft cloud
I can't believe it like yeah 15 years
ago it just seems like it seems like it
just became so quick that now everyone's
doing all these different cloud
computing technologies and onboarding
industry into cloud computing and and
sometimes it feels like you know when is
this going to come online for like
biotechnology which is a massive
industry and and how will it come online
for that because IOT seems like it's
sort of the big one right now
so walk us through what it's like to
have an industry that gets on-boarded
with Microsoft because I'm interested in
how this works so when I when I sign up
I have a certain amount of like you were
explaining either data or manufacturing
maybe I have robotics maybe I have
anything in that needs to connect to
your cloud for I'm paying you guys
monthly for you to help me with my data
with an analysis of the data with
understanding like you were explaining
earlier with the preet with predictive
maintenance all these types of things
that are helping me save money so you're
even trying to then take something like
what is normally a cost of paying you
monthly but actually you're saving the
company money by giving them the
decreases in cost of predictive
maintenance and things like that so can
you walk us through a couple like
industry let me back up a little in very
simply simplistically put going to the
cloud means basically using somebody
else's data centered in this case Asha
right of course that leaves a lot of the
complexity and and the idea was
originally that if you were a
manufacturing company and you had a you
have software running in your data
centers in your location that could be
back-end systems PL insistence and
whatever manufacturing execution systems
then now with the cloud you have the
option of running it in somebody else's
data center so so the first instinct of
everybody was what we call lift and
shift which is to take these
applications and instead of running them
in in that machine in my in my location
running them in Microsoft data center so
so that was not now the of course I mean
the first thing is that you don't have
to worry about the the physical machines
and the physical space and and updating
the machines and dealing with machines
that inevitably break down you for you
are outsourcing that to Microsoft right
Epic's versus all right so it's so even
for tax purposes is is is a yeah let me
so so the the and and also that is the
the concept that you don't have to you
don't have to provision hardware for for
your peak you can scale and it's
flexible right if one year you need you
have more projects or more production
you just ramped up more machines and
then you run them down so so it's the
elasticity right that and you're you're
essentially taking advantages of
economies of scale right we we buy
machines by the Balch and and we we
operate them in very efficient
environment so so you you pay less for
that right so that is that so so that's
that's the the first move was okay let's
move our stuff to to a cloud right now
more and more the independent software
vendors are developing cloud native
solutions right so so that brings that
brings a whole new paradigm it it's at
enable what we call software as a
service so so that's software that not
only does it run in the cloud but
basically it's based on subscription you
pay you pay a subscription think that
the most the easiest want to recognize
this office 365 right you probably
notice that you cannot really buy the
DVD of office 365 anymore you subscribe
to it so that's been enabled in in a big
part by the cloud so the combination of
of offshore of sourcing your data
centers and your hardware and and and
also enabling new business models where
you're actually subscribing to software
instead of buying the license
that's what manufacturing companies are
are and companies and all industries are
are evolving into so you want to talk
about taxes
this is the right time right now I'm not
going to talk about taxes it's not a fun
discussion yes because OPEX versus capex
discussion is actually interesting and
also planning
so it's relationally when you looked at
any typical data center for an
enterprise company it's been done in
cycles and the cycles are not in months
but years and what the IT departments
have been doing is that they're always
planning for the peak which means that
it's inevitable that you're going to
have unused capacity in your data center
and you'll be probably paying a lot for
just making sure that your business
continues running however with the
introducing interest in introducing the
called environments what should now you
can do is that you can basically use
resources and I would like to underline
the concept of resource but not the
different units like virtual machines
resources a key thing here resource
means it can be networking it can be
compute in terms of virtual machines it
can be computed in terms of serverless
servers are environments so you don't
really think about the server or the
virtual machine all you really think
about is this is the function I want to
run this is the resources that we'll
need in terms of CPU Network memory and
also higher level services like I don't
really care about this is a VM this is a
function or whatnot
what I care about is I want to process
the data industries it's streaming data
in a way that I want to apply a sequel
like query language on the streaming
data and that's all I want to all I want
to do in order just to be able to or
just looking at the capability of
provisioning such as resource where you
can basically apply a sequel like query
on a streaming data is actually pretty
quiet for a file because there's no
equivalent to it on the capex world
other than just buying large machine
yeah I'll add a few points and kind of
just I think they're still sort of some
of the fundamentals so I think you know
there's cloud there's no views white and
and in some respects and but if I broke
it down and - sort of from a Microsoft
perspective of course you know people
historically using things like onedrive
so obviously that's you think of cloud
storage of course office 365 is
obviously you know kind of thinking of
that subscription motion of using office
products in the cloud and then of course
we have Microsoft Azure Orem so some of
the fundamental things I think the line
that you think about it and and this
sort of probably lends itself to the way
sort of organizations or companies or
depending on the persona you are think
about cloud so if you're saying IT in a
company one of the things you'll think
about is potentially looking at data so
hot you know as Diego mentioned the law
a yacht I'm thinking about lifting
shifts so looking at you know you have
these things called virtual machines and
and data in the cloud and so on that you
can use so that's one of the most
fundamental primitive things you can do
and the reason for bringing it up is you
know that's kind of people generally
labor on the point of thinking of cloud
is okay I can move my date to the cloud
that's kind of one of the things and
it's a very fundamental IT
infrastructure type plane that's good
and data becomes a commodity and you
think about price point the other thing
just before I talk about the types of
motions across cloud is to to be really
clear at the benefits right so when you
think about cloud number one you're
moving to a pay-as-you-go model so
you're not per se moving to a
subscription model you abusing sway
pay for what you use model right so that
that's you know really transformational
and fundamental so if you think about
that model and then the capabilities of
being able to have things like virtual
machines that you provision think about
it you have your PC or your service
today in your data centers and be able
to say in a pay for what you use model
you're able to provision Hardware that
you can run in the cloud of you know
defining things like CPUs data and so on
so this is where people need to now sort
of understand it's not just I'm moving
data to the cloud it's now I have
computing power in the cloud and then
the third piece is we have calls provide
native services we have a hundred plus
services and cloud so they're all
enabling services it could be things
everything from driving workflows to
even thinking about things like data and
analytics and that's again part of our
goal when we talk about being able to
uplevel capabilities is to look at
industry and needs and provide
capabilities of clouds so then if you
think about that in in your mode of
operation and the personas it might be
I'm the IT guy that says ok I'm moving
my my core infrastructure my data to the
cloud great you have that model it might
be your persona is you're a developer so
I'm building on the clouds so instead of
thinking about and I'll introduce some
terminologies now so instead of thinking
about infrastructure as a service that
lift and shift model where I'm just
looking at pure sort of you know
capabilities of a cloud I'm thinking
about building on the cloud and this is
where we have a term called platform
as-a-service
this is where you're now leveraging
cloud capabilities as a developer
building on the cloud and then releasing
your your capabilities to be consumed
right so so in the infrastructure of the
service model really you're responsible
for those sets of capabilities for those
virtual machines you're provisioning
you're responsible things like upgrades
and so on so forth you have that
manageability kind of admin kind of
requirements in platform as-a-service
that's where those requirements are now
enable you if I looked at the developer
persona to be able to build on the cloud
but that we - we as Microsoft take away
that management and the maintainability
and the hardware that you're building on
the services that you use and then the
third scenario is software as a service
this is consuming services this is a
little as you think about things like
office 365 so I think as people you know
I talk a lot about transformation I talk
a lot about cloud and people are at
different stages you know I think people
need to evolve and understand that cloud
is not just data storage it's not just
one driver that's not just office 365
it's a paradigm shift it's a set of
capabilities it's thinking about
computing power in the cloud and
depending on your your persona you're
gonna think about it very differently
and then picking up on edgings
perspective on that sort of capital
expenditure version versus effects
imagine you're the CIO you're the CIO of
a company that's acquiring companies
while number one it's hard enough to
look at a five-year amortization of
saying here's my buying and then what
does that amortization look like on the
hardware imagine you're acquiring
company stand
cRIO now has pressure to say I don't
know tomorrow which new net new
companies I'm buying and then when I do
that that might plan my 5-year plan on
capital expenditure and hardware now
it's gonna be very very different well
imagine the world we're in the cloud you
don't have to do that forward planning
in a pay-as-you-go model you can
provision that infrastructure on demand
for what you need that's where the magic
starts to come in and this is this is
now you have almost infinite scale you
pay for what you use you can scale up
scale down and it makes that that
planning cycle much much much easier and
it flips that capex and that up X model
so just again just just kind of really
wanting to learn the point because it's
important I feel for us to educate the
market around what cloud really is
beyond thinking about Dropbox or
onedrive or data to its achieving much
much more than that yeah that was such a
good lesson I that was a really good one
so I'm happy that you three broke it
down like that the the one of the first
really profound ways of shifting was
this this mentality of like elasticity I
really like that word a lot so then the
the the industries get to pay for what
they use and they can really like you
said when they have big periods of
increasing their compute and this is a
major part of the future as well it
seems as though just cloud computing in
general and what is being used with the
you said there's a hundred plus services
that you offer in the cloud so you know
then the question is asked well what are
the services that you provide versus
what other cloud computes provide so
then now what are your proprietary
algorithms that you help industry with
and so then who's getting into the the
quantum computing world who's gonna be
offering that as a service these are all
very interesting questions that that
that we like to that we like to ask and
get into into that we like to get into
detail with can you guys speak a little
bit about the what it looks like you
know with 15 years now of getting
industry involved in cloud computing and
then what does these next 15 years
potentially look like for all of the
different offerings that
cloud computing organizations are are
going to it seems like quantum computing
is in there it seems like trying to use
potentially blockchain technologies in
order to make a decentralized version of
of the digital Ledger's for people to to
be able to use what do you guys think
about that this next sort of period of
time so let me I think there's a couple
of questions in there and so one was
sort of the parity with the cloud
lenders so I guess I'll answer the
question this way I mean you know the
market is the market and everyone can
kind of take a look at sort of market
share and what that looks like
in terms of sort of services and
capabilities this goes back to that
fundamental paradigm change that we
talked about that we had as a company so
what I feel good about with the
Microsoft is your cloud and when we
think about capabilities and services of
course we're always looking left to
right in terms of what other cloud
providers are providing you can that's
kind of a given in common business sense
but more importantly with course look
very closely and work with all community
so for example being here at code fest
today so you know when we think about
delivering capabilities in the cloud and
when we think about our planning that's
not done in isolation or an ivory tower
there's a lot of you know really working
closely with our customers and partners
and being involved and then being part
of our planning cycle so with all that
my point is our goal and I think we do a
really really nice job of this is that
we stay connected to understand yeah you
hear things about you know minimal
Viable Product and minimal liable
capabilities and so on and continuous
integration and continuous delivery we
do that very very well and we've
actually shifted that over the last few
years that in terms of the way we
deliver software and of course you know
a lot of that was driven through how we
deliver our cloud platform so I feel
good about our feedback loop we have
with the community and how we prioritize
the capabilities we deliver and I think
that's also reflected in when you go
look at things like yeah good locations
people want to look at some some
lighthouse winds who's go to enterprise
Microsoft calm you'll see some other
customer stories of customers building
on the Microsoft Azure cloud so I feel
good about that to sort of answer your
question and we continually look to
evolve and see the water the set of
capabilities we need to deliver that are
helping really helping our custom
and partner solve those problems in
terms of forward-looking who's kind of
always a fun kind of question of what's
next you know sometimes it's good to
look back to say what's next so you know
certainly things at a point of mind if I
think about three things and I talked
about this yesterday cloud data in AI
sort of things at a point in mind that
obviously are pivotal at the moment that
is sort of driving transformation so if
I look at sort of the he renowned
forward which is sort of I think the
evolution of some of those technologies
you know we're just going to continue to
evolve cloud that's gonna continue to
grow and you'll see more services and so
on and an expansion number one of course
artificial intelligence and augmented
reality is is a hot topic I think the
the big thing there is with cloud and
capabilities and price point that's
number one but with the advancements and
things like algorithms around the
artificial intelligence that's opening
up a new generation of just capabilities
there so I think you can see much much
more on the artificial intelligence and
it's probably one of the most
talked-about things across all the
industries I work on in terms of you
know everything from you know thinking
about anomaly detection to
personalization and so on so forth I
mean there's lots and lots of great
things even thinking from a development
point of view how do we use artificial
intelligence to actually generate
software so there's some really really
cool interesting things happening you
know that are going beyond sort of PhD
in science projects to reality and I
think you have this nice coming together
this intersection of technology and
algorithm is incapable of these
capabilities that's making this a
reality you talk about quantum computing
of course we've made announcements
around that it's obviously the next big
thing and if you kind of avoid look at
that that's gonna be super exciting and
we have obviously we're working with
some of the world-renowned leaders on
that of what that looks like so that's
an interesting one to track blockchain
you also mention you'd hit and all the
favorite topics at the moment my belief
there is it's it's super interesting as
I talked about in the keynote yesterday
the key thing there is gonna be the use
cases you know there's been a lot of
confusion between crypto currency and
blockchain and so that I think is not
being good for driving forward momentum
but I think that those the Moody
the waters have cleared around things
like blockchain now and so there's a lot
of great work across industries with
consortiums that have really sort of
thought leaders in the industries
thinking through what's the set of
problems where this technology might be
be useful so I think that's really
really really really interesting and I
think we're both external mental reality
is super interesting as well so you're
kind of blurring the lines of the two
yeah what I would add to that is that
one of the things that we're very keen
on when it comes to kind of what's
coming next in manufacturing and
technology is its focusing on the worker
and and and this is not just because
it's nice to say it is big because it's
the right thing to do from the societal
point of view it's also because it makes
sense I mean automation and machine
learning and all those cool technologies
work best when they augment the human
powers so it's about working with
automation along with automation instead
of automation replacing the human being
so we get sometimes too excited about
technology and we want to automate so
anything and and within that AI is magic
and and now we we are sobering up a
little bit and and we are seeing very
tangible use cases with machine learning
and artificial intelligence and robotics
and all that where they're actually
saving real dollars and and we we like a
lot those applications where where
they're incorporating the the human and
they're getting the best of both words
if you try to just ignore it no I mean
it's not only from the point of view of
jobs and and skills which is a very
important point it's just because it
makes more sense to augment the human
powers and rather than to try to replace
them with with technology so in that
regard I think the best best indication
indicator of the future is always the
past right so looking at the computing
story it's all about it has always been
about access the capacity and also the
speed so when computers
first started it was basically in this
huge room with one single computer
probably a few operators and the only
interface was a bunch of papers right
just look at how it changed over the
past the access to it start to increase
the speeds the data get transferred
continue to continue to increase the
excess the accessibility of that start
to again continue to agree increase what
I what we will see I think is that we're
going to have a lot of more a lot more
people and things that are connected
because the highway the information
highway is much broader and also with
the cap with the capacity increased
capacity on the overall computing
platforms you mention quantum computing
that's one of the other things that it's
all about how fast am I going to process
the data and run the algorithm so that I
can do a good thing and it goes back to
Diego's point again that the one thing
that were of course going to be seeing
in the future is that I don't know where
those numbers come from but that the
number of jobs lost to automation versus
the new jobs that are going to be
created by automation there's some crazy
numbers elimination of jobs is a
displacement just like what was the
number like hundred and thirty three
million new jobs because of the new
technology is something like that it's
it's it's it's fascinating and the way
that people access to technology the way
that we see things going on going
forward
is just me being ultimate geek I cannot
be more excited about it there's so many
good things there is well I I'm totally
in agreeance that I think a lot of the
conversations that are happening around
a job loss I think is very important to
realize that it takes so many designers
and engineers and cloud computing
architects to be able to to piece
together the new age that's being put
together but how do we retrain the the
millions of jobs that are that are in
the driving and the and the retail and
service industry how do they get
retrained into these positions is a very
difficult thing to fit to figure out
there's so many other things that you
guys talked about in there the three
words cloud data nai and we're where
we're going with that I really
appreciate it I didn't get to touch on
this but when you explained a
platform-as-a-service it's very
interesting to think about someone being
able to take their own proprietary
compute putting it up on your cloud and
then offering that to other people
that's a whole new you're acting as like
a marketplace as well for people to put
up their own stores in the cloud
basically for people to access that's
that's very interesting and then of
course on the on the on the actual
augmenting a work side of things this is
very key can actually save real dollars
by by augmenting work instead of
replacing it and all these new jobs that
are opening up us as we said and then
just on the on the decentralization side
of things I also am very fascinated by
if as we go into the computing the
quantum computing cloud world is are we
going to see companies like Microsoft
like Google that are at the forefront of
these industries are we gonna have silos
of cloud computing are we gonna open up
the algorithms for them for going across
the silos for people to use do you guys
have any last thoughts about you know
about that little bit so I mean in terms
of kind of the algorithms and I can go
up I mean I think that's already there
I'm and today and I think I yank yeah
absolutely yeah and we'll kind of pass
it along and so I mean I think that's
why you're seeing such a thriving
ecosystem around the artificial
intelligence is the sharing of the
algorithms and that people can can
leverage that and I think as you touch
upon it earlier on as well as that
you know we are the largest contributor
to open source that but I'll pass along
I mean gotta share some thoughts on that
yes yes and the acquisition of github by
Microsoft is actually a very interesting
indicator of that so Microsoft's culture
has been changing yes and it's all been
changing towards being more open
providing access to the those
technologies that were not accessible
before so another example here is that
it's a first of all just full full
disclosure I'm little lawyer right so
what I'm going to tell is about some law
related law related stuff but it's
actually very important for the startups
and for new businesses Microsoft has a
new service called as your IP protection
so this is all about an IP just pretty
much like any other acronym it does not
mean that it's Internet Protocol its
intellectual property it's all about
Microsoft opening up patents that are
really important and key for the
technology to thrive and letting the use
of those patents available
Microsoft also expanded IP protection
services to the startups which allows
the startups to not to be afraid of the
there so there's an interesting term for
that I love it it's not patent trolls
it's non-practicing entities which are
equivalent by the way so those people
those companies who Douglas who just
happen to have ownership over patent but
not necessarily producing anything on
top of that so they're not practicing
anything using that patent this that set
up actually may prevent a lot of
up-and-coming startups and businesses
that can solve new problems to just hold
back because they're afraid of being
sued by those entities and and they
Center and they cannot go forward for
forward with interesting solutions just
because of the legal problems so those
two things the IP protection and
Microsoft opening up those patents are
actually amazing contributions to the
community who want to do additional work
on
of the existing intellectual property
that is that is it thank you so much for
joining us
Diego jank Paul thank you so much this
has been fascinating I feel like I have
been more really well more well informed
now about what's happening in cloud and
hopefully for everyone that's tuning in
as well we greatly appreciate you tuning
in and give us your thoughts in the
comments below about everything that was
described about Microsoft's cloud
computing a sure and more go share it
with other people we'd love to hear the
more conversations happening around the
world about this up and coming
technology huge shout out to Co fest Co
fesses links are below as well and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in our links are below as well
thanks everyone for tuning in and we
will see you soon